China's government is angry and
threatening a forceful response after
taiwan's president met yesterday in
California with house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy and other members of Congress
the Biden Administration says the
president's visit did nothing to provoke
China Elizabeth Palmer has more from
Taiwan
good morning the meeting between
taiwan's President and speaker McCarthy
was first and foremost a clear signal to
China her arrival and welcome by the
speaker in a bipartisan group of
lawmakers was meant to Telegraph that
America would come to the rescue if
China tried to seize Taiwan by force
their presence and unwavering support
reassure the people of Taiwan that we
are not isolated and we are not alone
this was a choreographed show of
solidarity the friendship between the
people of Taiwan and America is a matter
of profound importance to the Free World
predictably China was Furious
today the foreign Ministry spokeswoman
warned it would use strong and Resolute
measures to defend its sovereignty
last time a warning like that meant an
intimidating display of force China's
missiles planes and warships all around
Taiwan
that was in August 2022 after then
speaker Nancy Pelosi visited the island
to meet with President Tsai seven months
on life in Taipei is ticking along as
people are getting used to the tension
and now bracing themselves for yet more
Chinese reprisals
Michael Cole is an analyst with the
Republican Institute in Taipei there is
absolutely no doubt that they will do
something to try to punish Taiwan as a
result of president's eyes particularly
over her meeting with uh with speaker
McCarthy and to add fuel to the fire the
chairman of the house Foreign Affairs
committee Michael McCall has just landed
here in Taipei with a bipartisan
delegation to meet senior officials
including president Tsai
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Taipei